Let me begin with a quote
by Marcus Garvey from his
Declara--Declaration of
Rights for the Negro Peoples
of the World. One of his
points reads: "We believe in
the freedom of Africa for
the Negro people of the
world, and by the principle
of Europe for the Europeans
and Asia for the Asiatics;
we also demand Africa for
the Africans at
home and abroad."
Today I want to pick up on
the theme I ended the last
lecture with, and that
is that black Americans,
talking heading--talking
about the nineteen-teens,
heading
into--into World War I,
we're now in the wake of
the challenges of that era,
and the domestic
disappointments of World War
I, when soldiers came
home and some were lynched,
that black Americans were
going to claim their civil
rights instead of wait
patiently for them. These
were, as a group--and I'm
generalizing here--the New
Negroes. This is a term
used now and again really
after 1900, and one of
the first proponents of the
phrase was Booker T.
Washington, but using it in
a--in a very different way.
I'm using it in a very
different way than--than
Washington was using it.
When people talk about New
Negroes, they're most often
using it in a very different
way than Washington
intended. Anyway,
these were the New Negroes,
this new--this new kind of
black consciousness that
really becomes articulated
on a wide scale when black
troops come home after World
War I; the New Negro that
was forged out of political
and economic frustration.
And it's always important to
remember that this
frustration grew out of more
than just
returning soldiers;
It grew out of the race
riots of 1917 and 1919;
It grew out of the cultural
shocks and changes that were
part of the Great Migration
as well. I want to show an
image right now that
captures some of that
spirit. "The
New--The New Negro crowd,
making America safe for
himself." It's a play of
Woodrow Wilson's, "The New
Neg--the word--just drew a
complete blank."
"Making the world
safe for democracy?"
Thank you so much.
"Making the world safe for
democracy." I
don't know why,
it's a--it's
already a long day.
Anyway, you see a--a black
troop in an Army jeep or
some kind of vehicle, the
New Negro blazoned on the
side, guns coming out in
all directions. He's going
after German troops, giving
the Hun a dose of his own
medicine. But notice the
banner that he's carrying:
Longview, Texas, the
site of a race riot;
Washington DC, a
Chicago, Illinois, site of
a race riot. "Since the
government won't
stop mob violence,
I'll take a hand."
The New Negro, in this
case the black soldier,
"If Wilson can't do
it for black soldiers,
for black citizens, if
the country can't do it,
blacks will take it upon
themselves to do it." This
is--This editorial cartoon
is yet one manifestation of
a New Negro mentality.
Another point--hmm--Another
aspect that's important to
understand about the New
Negro mentality, and
this phenomenon in general,
was that it wasn't just
about black self-assertion,
like this--this cartoon
suggests. It was also about
white reaction. The white
reaction to the New--to the
New Negro manifests itself
in negative and positive
ways. The positive
ways, although fraught with
complication, will be
really the foundation for
Wednesday's lecture. Today
we're going to hear more
about the more obvious
negative manifestations of
white reaction to this
New Negro mentality. The
most--the clearest
manifestation of course is
the rise of the lynch mob,
again the resurrection of
the Klan.
But from an
institutional standpoint,
from the
standpoint of the state,
the most negative
manifestation of white
reaction to the New
Negro mentality is federal
surveillance. The riots
of 1917 and 1919 made white
politicians nervous.
Property was at stake,
after all. Perhaps it goes
without saying that these
pol--same politicians
easily ignored the real race
dynamics of the riots, where
white employers and property
owners, black
and white--well,
black and white
property owners,
in terms of raising
rents--but white employers
and property owners attacked
and organized attacks
against black residents.
This anxiety is deeply felt
and broadly felt and becomes
manifest in a very famous
way with one politician in
particular. The story for
this person begins in 1919.
The person I'm talking about
is twenty-four years
old, twenty-four years old,
a native of Washington,
D.C. Becomes the head of
the Department of
Justice's new organization,
the General
Intelligence Division,
the GID. A young man.
His job is to keep tabs on,
and I'm quoting
here, "liberal activity,
whatever that's going
to mean. Among other
organizations
being investigated,
you have a wide range
of black groups that are
targeted for some sort
of investigation. The
conservative Black Elks, who
are anything but liberal,
to the radical and
separatist African Blood
Brotherhood. The
man in question is J.
Edgar Hoover. His
leadership of the General
Intelligence--Intelligence
Division,
parlays himself into the
directorship--directorship
of the FBI when that
organization was formed.
And it's a position that he
would hold until his death
in 1972. People have
claimed that he was the most
powerful person in the
country. And there's a lot
of merit to that kind of
claim for the way that he
investigates seemingly
everybody. Now why does
Hoover's foundational moment
matter? It matters in part
because of Hoover's
worldview. When race riots
occur in
Washington, D.C., Hoover,
who is a native of the area,
concluded that their cause
lay in the, quote,
"series of"--excuse,
excuse me. "The numerous
assaults committed by
negroes against white
women." Once again,
the trope appears, the fear
of black male interlopers
attacking or--or luring
white women. But aside from
this recurring trope that
demonized black males and
exalted white women, why
is Hoover's so--story so
important? It's important
not only because Hoover
would organize obsessive
campaigns against Martin
Luther King, Jr., and social
activist groups in the
1960s--and we'll--we'll
come to this later on in the
course--because it--but it's
also important because it's
under Hoover's
leadership that the federal
surveillance of African
Americans starts and its
most intense focus of this
surveillance rests upon a
black nationalist Jamaican,
who took up residence in
Harlem in 1916. And I'm
talking here about Marcus
Garvey. Garvey's
born in Jamaica in 1887,
but he is mainly educated
in London. Now there's no
little irony in the
fact that this person who
eventual--eventually fights
against the spread of a
white empire that oppresses
black people around the
world, and who organizes
this fight by calling for
his own black empire,
there's no little irony in
the fact that he himself
was trained in the seat of
empire.
Apparently while in London,
he learned his lessons
well. A colonial subject,
trained in the heart of
the--of colonial control,
who ends up advocating a new
colonial presence. I mean
in a nutshell, this is
sort of the--the sort of
fundamental irony
of Marcus Garvey,
and I'll be expanding upon
it through the course of the
lecture. Anyway, Garvey's
educated for the most part
in London and returns
to Jamaica in 1914,
and he has a plan. Having
learned how to organize
movements and how--how
empire operated at its core,
he decides in short order to
organize the Universal Negro
Improvement Association, the
UNIA. In formulating his
plan for the UNIA,
Garvey was inspired by
Washington's--Booker T.
Washington's Up
From Slavery.
This book, published at
the turn of the century,
but its most famous section
or chapter is the story of
Washington's famous Atlanta
Cotton Exposition address,
something that Garvey,
sort of from an ideological
standpoint, embraced. Now
Garvey's not interested in
that element of Washington's
plan that called for at
least temporary
accommodation to the white
South, but he was
committed ideologically,
deeply so, to Washington's
idea of economic
self-sufficiency. If you
remember back to Washington,
"in all things truly social,
separate as the fingers."
Garvey soon realized
that his plan to emancipate
blacks by
economic empowerment,
that his plan to emancipate
blacks across the globes
with the vehicle of
empire formation,
would not take off in
Jamaica. The platform was
too small. Two years after
he comes back to Jamaica,
he decides that if he really
wanted to get at the heart
and soul of blacks
throughout the world,
he had to move his operation
to what was then popularly
considered the heart
of the black world,
and that's New York
City, more specifically,
Harlem. Now this is all
a rather new phenomenon,
Harlem, as far as being the
sort of the center of the
black world, as again
popularly felt. This is a
direct result of the Great
Migration. And as we'll see
on--on Wednesday's lecture,
sort of focusing a fair
amount of what's happening
in Harlem for particular
reasons. But for the
standpoint of propagating a
message,
demographics and such,
New York City was the place
to be. Garvey's family had
a background in
typesetting and printing,
and he gets his own
training in publishing,
and quickly produces
a magazine or paper,
called the Negro World, a
journal that serves as the
mouthpiece for his
nationalist philosophy of
racial--race pride and
race unity. In short order,
when he moves his
operation to New York City,
Negro World would have the
second largest circulation
of black
periodicals in the country,
second only to the Chicago
Defender. So it's sort of
out of the blue, Garvey
steps into the fray and
becomes incredibly popular,
as does his periodical.
Garvey would claim, soon, up
to six million followers.
Although there were never
nearly that many official
Garveyites, the best
estimates of official
followers of
Garvey's movement,
members of the UNIA,
were around five hundred
thousand. But there's no
doubting the importance of
the UNIA, or--or the
significance of Garvey
himself. The UNIA
established laundries,
groceries, and other retail
operations that were by and
for black people,
or, more accurately,
UNIA members. The UNIA was
about instilling race pride,
and Garvey embodied it with
ostentatious displays that
smacked--more than
smacked of--that,
that represented sort of
the logic of--of empire. He
would organize these parades
with his auxiliaries,
black UNIA members
dressed up in uniforms,
in hierarchy, in
orders, marching in parades,
Garvey as the grand
marshal, epaulets,
gold buttons and
trim, plumage,
all the trappings of the
benevolent--benevolent
emperor. This was a
performance certainly that
was designed to instill
race pride among sojourning
blacks who were struggling
with city life. Indeed,
the most popular--or Garvey
and his movement were the
most popular amongst
individuals who were fairly
recently arrived--arrived to
the cities. The UNIA then
inspires hope for the future
and also racial solidarity.
You can go to a safe space,
a UNIA laundry or grocery
store, or just
another store,
buy what you need and
believe that you're not
getting ripped off like you
were if you were going to a
share--a, a planters' store,
if you were a sharecropper,
or if you're one generation
removed from sharecropping.
You could buy from the race,
be treated with respect,
and be part of something
bigger than yourself. Now
Garvey's aware that
there's a growing desire for
self-determination by
oppressed people around the
world, especially after
World War I. And Garvey,
aside from just having these
stores and these parades,
marries this desire for
self-determination with a
call for blacks to return
to Africa and to build their
own country. This was
not just the trappings of
military and of empire in
terms of just what you're
dressed in, what
you're wearing,
but also a call to actually
create that space back in
Africa. Garvey first
tries to get permission to
establish his own
colony in Africa,
his target is Liberia, but
he's denied permission.
Upset over the rebuff,
Garvey decides to form
quasi-militaristic groups
that were designed to kick
whites out of Africa. He
even declared himself the
provisional President of
the new Empire of Africa,
naming potentates
to rule with him,
and creating a nobility
of--of anointed knights. He
wanted all the sort
of the trappings,
the declarations, of
empire. Maybe this might
get him there, but to no
avail. But he does organize
something that, for
a moment it seems,
at least for a
lot of followers,
seems that Garvey might be
more than just about words
and retail operations,
and this is the Black Star
Steamship Line.
This is the crown
jewel of Garvey's efforts,
the UNIA's efforts. Garvey
unfolds his plan in 1919,
again, this
incredibly important year,
this changing notion of
poss--possibility with
African Americans--unfolds
his plan in 1919 to build
the steamship line, and he
sees it as representing an
effort to demonstrate black
self-sufficiency and truly
the potential for black
nation-building. Now this
is an era you need to
realize that you built
nations, you express
international power,
by navies. And Garvey's
idea is eventually to build
his navy and have
that be the vehicle,
literally and figuratively,
the vehicle for his empire.
By 1920, the Black Star
Steamship Line is now the
focus of Garvey's Back to
Africa movement. And he
starts to sell bonds to
raise money to purchase
these ships. These ships
would embody black power.
They would have
all black crews,
for example. They would be
the means for blacks to get
to Africa.
They would become the
lynchpin of the global
economy. Garvey
shares this idea,
this vision,
this excitement,
and within three months
of his first call for
contributions to
purchase a ship,
he buys his first ship. It
seems to me--to be that this
might actually happen, at
least some change. Well,
the Black Star Steamship
Line quickly becomes
Garvey's undoing. The
steamship line ends up being
three ships over the course
of the steamship line's
existence. Garvey
drastically overpaid for
each of the three ships.
The first ship he probably
paid eight--eight hundred
percent more than he should
have. The
captain, as it turns out,
was taking kickbacks. The
second ship sprang a leak
and sank shortly after the
UNIA purchased it. And the
third ship blew a boiler on
its maiden voyage and killed
a man. A comedy of errors
and tragedies. But when
those ships that actually
proved seaworthy for a
little while, when the ships
actually did make it to a
port of call, traveling up
and down the North American
seaboard on the East Coast,
thousands of black well
wish--well wishers
crowded the piers,
stand on the hillsides,
wanting to catch a glimpse
of the first all-black crew
that they had ever seen.
Certainly the Black Star
Line was a complete business
fiasco, there's no
doubting about that,
but it was a powerful symbol
for black possibility. For
that reason alone it
would be important. But the
importance doesn't end
there. The Black Star Line,
the business
dealings that it created,
remain important for
the shady financing that
eventually gives J.
Edgar Hoover the hook that
he needed to snare Garvey.
We can't forget Hoover
through all of this.
Garvey's mass popularity
his appeals for race pride,
his haughty
imperialist style,
all of these conspire to
make people like Hoover more
than a little worried. Now
the fact is although that we
will never know how
many people were actually
following Garvey, his
movement did represent the
first organized grassroots
mass protest movement in
African American history.
It was the first organized
grassroots mass protest
movement in African American
history. So if one
were concerned about black
autonomy, and one were
already convinced that
blacks,
particularly black males,
represented a
perpetual threat,
then Garvey's
UNIA, Garvey himself,
would have appeared
terrifying. What was he
going to do? When you
add the specter of Garvey,
the mass
movement of the UNIA,
to the violence in 1917 and
1919 ripping through cities
where the UNIA was
at its most powerful,
then you would
have been convinced,
if you were
someone like Hoover,
that something had to
be done. So Hoover took
action. He decides he's
going to put Garvey in jail
and then sets out to find
a justification for his
arrest. So he knows he's
going to put him in jail;
he's got to find a way to do
it. The first thing Hoover
does is hire four black
agents and assign them to
infiltrate the UNIA.
It's really remarkable,
the Garvey Papers, it's a
massive collection. Yale
has it on microfilm, and you
can look at the reports from
these agents going
back to their superiors,
bits of
information redacted,
as we become used to
in our modern world.
The--some--sometimes just
sort of--it's the level of
silliness about
going to, you know,
Mrs. Johnson's
last night for,
you know, for her suspected
UNIA involvement. She made
a wonderful pie and we
drank tea. I mean this is,
you know, the extent of
some of the reports. The
rep--the infiltration
did not get very far.
Hoover then tries to prove
that Garvey was an agent of
the British or
Canadian governments,
which made--which would have
made him something like an
unregistered foreign agent.
I mean, this is
rather stretching things,
since the British and
Canadian governments really
aren't such powerful enemies
of the United States,
but this was still Hoover's
next gambit. It doesn't
work. Garvey's star is
rising. We're not into the
1920s. Then Hoover finally
succeeds in getting him
indicted--gets him indicted
on mail fraud charges. Gets
Garvey thrown in jail in
1925 for five years. But
before Garvey's term
could be completed,
he's pardoned by President
Calvin Coolidge on the
condition that he
leaves the country,
that he's deported as an
undesirable alien at the
moment of his release from
jail. So Hoover gets mail
fraud charges
leveled against Garvey in
twenty-three. He's in jail
in twenty-five. He's out in
twenty-seven, but he
is sent down to Jamaica
immediately. With
Garvey's deportation,
federal surveillance of
blacks basically disappears
until the start of World War
II. And it's really quite
shocking that it disappears,
because this is an era of
real radicalism, as you'll
see in the--the Manning
Marable reader
for this week,
this week and next week.
This is an era of real
political radicalism, yet
Hoover was so focused on
Garvey and his exhortations
of a Back to Africa movement
and race pride that the
other organizations just
don't merit his attention,
not nearly to the same level
of attention.
Once Garvey's gone,
"the problem" is gone. Now
what are the charges? What
of the, the--those sort of
steps that got Garvey kicked
out of the country?
And what about Garvey's
relationship to other
blacks? I mean he was not
the only black
leader of this era. And,
also, what shall we make of
Garvey's political legacy?
The charges were
literally trumped up,
but they were actually
basically true. Garvey was
at best an inept, and
at worst a dishonest,
businessman. He sold bonds
many times over when he
shouldn't have
been selling them,
to raise money for his
ships. He did commit mail
fraud. Is it enough to
deport somebody? That's
another issue. What about
his relationship with black
leaders? Other
black leaders,
the most prominent ones, did
not have a high opinion of
Garvey. Du Bois, who
offered information to
Hoover to try to get Garvey
in trouble. Du Bois called
him, and I quote, "a
little fat black man,
ugly, but with intelligent
eyes and a big head." He
was to Du Bois, quote, "the
most dangerous enemy of the
Negro race in
American--Americas and the
world, either a
lunatic or a traitor." A.
Philip Randolph, a powerful
labor leader that we'll be
talking about next week,
referred to Garvey--whose,
whose, who is powerful
at this moment in time,
referred to
Garvey as, quote,
"the supreme negro
Jamaican jackass,
or a monumental monkey, who
is also an unquestionable
fool, an ignoramus."
Why such anger? Jealousy,
certainly part of the
equation. Du Bois had been
struggling for his entire
adult life to build the kind
of movement that Garvey
shows up and builds within
three or four
years. Du Bois,
powerful intellect,
influential editor,
but he cannot command the
same kind of numbers and
followers as Garvey
could. Randolph,
a rising labor leader,
couldn't command the kind of
following and passions that
Garvey could. So certainly
jealousy, but there's also
an awareness of what they
saw, what Du Bois
and Randolph saw,
as limitations to Garvey's
agenda. How was a Back to
Africa movement really going
to happen? Was it even
possible? There have been
Back to Africa movements for
a hundred years
at this point,
led by black radicals, led
by very conservative whites,
led by progressive
whites. You know,
everybody, politically
across the spectrum,
was trying to figure out a
way to get blacks out of the
country. None
of them worked.
They logistically weren't
feasible. So what's Garvey
selling here? Du Bois and
Randolph says our problems,
blacks' problems, are here
on this soil. We need to
solve them here. Du Bois
and Randolph wondered if
Garvey was merely preying
on the wild aspirations of
those people who could least
afford to invest their money
in his plan. Garvey raised
money from a lot of recent
migrants to places like
New York and Chicago,
Detroit, people who didn't
have much money at all to
spend, not extra, not
disposable income. Du Bois
and Randolph
believed that they,
in their own separate ways,
were leading the charge to
care for this most
vulnerable population,
and that Garvey was doing
something different. And
now what about Garvey's
political legacy? Was it
radical or was it
conservative? Was Garvey a
revolutionary,
like Hoover believed,
or was he merely a black
capitalist? Did he want to
save Africa, or merely
establish economic and
political control over
part of it? I mean think of
this--of his militaristic
and imperialist trappings,
the performance of
his attire during these
parades. Think of the
rhetoric that I used to
begin the lecture, "We
demand Africa for the
Africans." To get at
some of the answers to these
questions--is
Garvey radical,
is he conservative,
revolutionary or
capitalist? Do you want to
save Africa for Africans or
for blacks--black
Americans?--to get at some
of the answers, it's useful
to--helpful to plumb the
depths of Garvey's
own publicly offered
philosophies. These are all
very short excerpts from the
Manning Marable and
Leith Mullings reader,
but I want to call your
attention to a few choice
phrases here. On race
pride and race suspicion,
I guess it's a
clumsy way of putting it,
Garvey is dumbfounded by
the white leadership of the
NAACP. "Du Bois," he said,
"represents a group that
hates the Negro blood in its
veins and has been working
subtly to build up a
caste aristocracy that would
socially divide the race
into two groups: one the
superior because of
color--of color caste,
and the other the inferior.
Hence the pretentious work
of the National Association
for the Advancement of
Colored People."
Now there's no doubt that
Du Bois--that Du Bois is an
elitist. There's no
doubting that. And that he
believed that the Talented
Tenth were the people to
save the race, but getting
into political bed with
these white progressives
Garvey thought was insane.
"You cannot trust white
people to do the right thing
in that regard." Du
Bois hated the blood in his
own--the, the quote, "Negro
blood in his own veins." On
racial self-preservation,
Garvey was against blacks
fighting for the United
States in World War I. He
says here, "The first dying
that is to be done by the
black man in the future
will be done to make himself
free. And then
when we are finished,
if we have any
charity to bestow,
we may die for
the white man.
But as for me, I think I
have stopped dying for him."
Powerful words. The kind of
words you might hear out of
a different revolutionary
some forty years later.
Similar--Similarly, "We
declare that no Negro shall
engage himself in the battle
for an alien race without
first attaining the consent
of the leader of the Negro
people of the world, except
in a matter of national
self-defense."
Blacks will not fight
unless the leader of the
Negro people says they
should fight. That would be
Garvey. And so
he said that,
you know, blacks should
not fight for the white man,
except as a matter
of national defense.
So when we do get our land,
our plot and what is or was
then and still is Liberia,
sort of is his real goal,
his first goal, then we
fight for self-defense. We
don't fight for them.
Speaking about racial pride,
Garvey had much to say:
"We have outgrown slavery,
he said, "but our minds
are still enslaved to the
thinking of the master
race. Now take those kinks
out of your mind instead of
out of your hair. You are
capable of--of all that
is common to men of other
races. We have a beautiful
history and we shall create
another one in the future.
The faith we have is the
faith that will ultimately
take us back to that ancient
place, that ancient position
that we once occupied when
Ethiopia was in her glory."
Can't trust whites, you
can't fight for whites,
you need to recognize the
glory of our own past. And
if this sounds a bit like
the civilizationist rhetoric
that I was talking
about two weeks or so ago,
you're exactly right.
Garvey was a civilizationist
in this way. "No
Negro," he said,
"let him be
American, European,
West Indian or African,
shall be truly respected
until the race as a
whole has emancipated itself
through self-achievement
and progress from universal
prejudice. The Negro
will have to build his own
government,
industry, art, science,
literature and culture
before the world will stop
to consider
him. Until then,
we are--we are but wards
of a superior race and
civilization and
the outcasts of a
standard--outcasts of a
standard social system. The
race needs
workers at this time,
not plagiarists,
copyists and mere imitators,
but men and women who
are able to create,
to originate and improve
and thus make an independent
racial
contriba--contribution to
the world and civilization."
The power is within
African Americans,
but they aren't expressing
it. And when they do tap
into those great things
from their own racial past,
recognize their long history
of civilizationist behavior,
looking back in antiquity,
when they take the kinks out
of their mind instead
of out of their hair,
then they will rise up,
demonstrate their greatness
to the world, be respected,
have their nation,
have their civilization,
and as part of this,
have their king. That would
be Garvey. Now just as
Garvey wasn't the only race
leader operating in this
sort of trying to
save the race mode,
you have Du Bois and you'll
have--you'll learn more
about A.
Philip Randolph next
week. There was another
charismatic individual at
the same time operating,
another African American,
who's really operating at
the other end of a sort of
spectrum of a sense from
Marcus Garvey, but also
tremendously popular. His
name's Father Divine. Well
that's his popular name.
His birth name
is George Baker,
known as Father Divine, and
also known by his followers
as "God." Father
Divine was born,
excuse me, was head of
the Peace Mission Movement,
that becomes very popular
during this era. But where
Garvey's UNIA was
absolutely monoracial,
it was black only, Divine's
was absolutely interracial.
In its very structure, black
and white come together.
Now while historians are
learning more about the--the
women in the UNIA and the
very important roles that
they played, from the
standpoint of the public
perception of the UNIA,
it's a very male ordered and
dominated organization.
Father Divine is a very
different sort of thing,
the Peace Mission Movement.
He relies on his Angels to
do a lot of work, black
women and white women. Now
there were some
similarities. The most
important for our purposes
right now is that both UNIA
and the Peace Mission
Movement were profoundly
self-help in
their orientation.
And it is in this way
that Father Divine,
like Garvey, was deemed
a threat--a threat to
authorities. He's deemed a
threat because he represents
to so many, black autonomy.
He's also deemed a threat
because he consorts openly
with white women in his
organization, has white
women involved in such
prominent positions.
Now quickly here,
who was Father Divine and
what did he do actually?
His early history is murky.
He's an itinerant preacher
who extolled the virtues of
what was called New Thought,
the power of positive
thinking regimen. That can
be seen as a precursor
of sorts to the New Age
ideologies of the 1980s.
God was in every person,
according to
Divine's philosophy,
but he was perfectly
manifested in Divine
himself. Divine
advocated, as I said before,
interracial life,
strict celibacy,
communal living,
and most famously,
communal feasts. He was
known for serving feasts
every Sunday at his various
peace missions that were
around the country,
and this was a national
organization. And these
feasts would run all day
long with seemingly
endless supplies of food,
available to anybody
who wanted to come by,
as long as he stayed
for the meal and for some
proselytizing. Divine
did not represent a Back to
Africa movement. He's
very Victorian in his style.
But he was determined
to support materially,
and also from the
standpoint of faith,
African Americans who were
overwhelmingly the people he
was serving, during this
age of great instability and
change. Garvey sees a
threat in Father Divine,
and he attacks Divine for
preaching race suicide,
celibacy and interracial
relationships. You don't
get more black babies
if you have interracial
relationships, and also
if you're really preaching
celibacy. The problem is,
is that many of Garvey's
followers also followed the
Peace Mission Movement. But
you can't reconcile the two
from the standpoint of their
ideologies. How do you make
sense of it? You make sense
of it in light
of the migration,
the violence of the era, and
the increasing poverty of
the era: overcrowded
cities, slum lords,
black and white,
charging exorbitant rents,
a lack of support, despite
the fact you might be
getting four dollars a day,
a lack of institutional and
structural support
for African American
communities. Garvey gave
hope to African Americans
who were poor
and struggling,
new to the city. He gave
them safe places to conduct
commerce.
Divine tapped into a sense
of a--a larger belonging,
of something much
greater than the individual,
to something
metaphysical perhaps,
and he fed people. So
thinking about Garvey and
Divine and how to make
sense of these two different
ideologies--one
race, interracial,
Back to Africa, taking care
of business here-- it sort
of undergirds the sense of
flux that the society's in
at the moment. People are
being opportunistic on the
ground, trying to find a
way to make ends meet,
to try to find a
better way of living,
better quality of
life. Exhausted by external
threats, whether it's
federal surveillance or the
Klan or simple,
systematic segregation,
blacks were scrambling.
Now it doesn't help that in
addition to this federal
surveillance and the rise of
the Klan, Garvey actually
goes to negotiate with the
Klan, with Klan leadership,
trying to get their support
for Back to Africa
politics. If you believe
the reports, the leaders of
the Klan and Garvey actually
admired each other about
at least being honest,
about not liking
the other person.
And they can find a way to
work together to get them
out of each other's hair.
Divine himself courts white
leaders of a very
different type than Klan,
the people with money who
bolster the Peace Mission
Movement's various
holdings. They own
all--they, they provide all
their own food. They own
all their own property.
They're a cash and carry
operation. A lot of it
was coming from white
benefactors. So you
have this curious mix of
high-level interactions
between blacks and whites in
Garvey and in the Peace
Mission Movement. You have
the erasure of that
interaction in the--in the
UNIA movement, because
you couldn't trust whites,
actually. You have the
embracing of it in the Peace
Mission Movement,
interra--interracial support
and cooperation.
You have an extensive,
a wide scope of interactions
when you sort of throw the
veil back from
all of this stuff,
between whites and blacks
during this era. Despite
the popularity of the UNIA,
despite the racial violence,
there is a great
amount of exchange,
politically, socially,
and culturally. And this
cultural exchange is
where we're going to pick up
matters on Wednesday. And
that's when I'll see you
again. Thank you very much.